wie lange sollte ich sport in der
schwangerschaft machen diese frage kann
mir jetzt hoffentlich gynäkologin doktor
china der ließ beantworten frau denise
sport in der schwangerschaft das ist ja
an sich okay aber bis wann denn man kann
tatsächlich bis zum schluss sport machen
werden werde es einem gut geht und wenn
es einem gut tut der mensch ist dafür
ausgelegt ja vor tausenden von jahren
als die menschen noch nomaden waren
mehrere strecken kilometer strecken am
tag hinter sich zu bringen ihre kinder
sind zehn frauen sind zäh und solange
man keine kommunikation hat kann man
eigentlich bis zum schluss das heißt das
heißt reiten hochleistungssport alles
bis zum 9 monat okay also es gibt ich
sage meinen patienten immer und jede
sportart machen was nicht mit einer
erhöhten verletzungsrisiko einhergeht
ja also reiten gehört dazu aber fahren
ist gefährlich alles wo du dich bei
verletzten kannst alles wo du dir ein
bein brechen kann beispielsweise das
sollte ich nicht machen
im hochleistungssport ich schaffe man
wahrscheinlich nicht vor der körper der
schwangeren irgendwann sagt stopp aber
solange man nicht blutet und solange man
keine schmerzen sagt und solange man
regelmäßig zur vorsorge geht und der
frauen hat es immer noch sagt ja es in
ordnung alles gut spricht nichts dagegen